normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government false
us demographic changes so they go on to
bring up the great replacement Theory
and I love how they do this ABC news
says ramas Swami also boosted the great
replacement Theory the white nationalist
belief that immigration policies are
designed specifically to dilute the
political power of white Americans by
making them a smaller share of the
population the idea has been elevated by
media figures like Tucker Carlson and
inspired Mass violence in 5 Charleston
South uh Carolina church Massacre and in
the 2019 shooting at Walmart ramas Swami
alleged during the debate that the
theory is not some Grand right-wing
conspiracy theory but a basic statement
of the democratic party platform how
about I just play this video of Van
Jones for you and we'll start breaking
this down asking the white majority to
do something that's
difficult and I think it' be easier if
we just acknowledge that it's difficult
no ethnic majority group in 10,000 years
of human history that I can find ever
went from being a m majority to being a
minority and liked it and that's
basically the request from the racial
Justice left is that we want the white
majority to go from being a majority to
being a minority and like it that's a
tough
request and the reality is it changes
hard change that you want is hard change
it as good as hard so the racial Justice
left according to him is asking the
white majority to go from being a
majority to a minority there's only two
ways that happens one Mass migration and
white people not having kids if they're
asking white people to do this they're
outright saying we want a policy of mass
migration and we don't want you to have
kids there's a third way it's
genocide right right right I suppose you
know in my context I'm talking about
what's currently going on right now in
this country peaceful ways to do it but
we have this this great article from
Newsweek Democrats are massive
Hypocrites on so-called great
replacement the Theory and this is by
Pedro Gonzalez from 2022 in Newsweek
where he breaks down statements from Joe
Biden and many other Democrats where
they're outright basically saying this
they're outright saying it uh he says
the mass shooting in Buffalo New York
was an atrocity the killer will pay for
his life the suspect left behind a 180
page document outlining a schizophrenic
worldview we get that Biden and the
company latched onto it but here's the
problem Democrats and Progressive
activists based on their own rhetoric
over the years subscribe to replacement
Theory more than anyone else as Vice
President Biden himself said that a
constant and unrelenting stream of
immigration would reduce Americans of
white European stock to an absolute
minority and that was a source of our
strength I'm not going to go through the
whole article because pedo actually
brings up a ton of other excellent
examples but I think right there when
you have Joe Biden who is now the
president saying a source of our
strength is an unrelenting stream of
immigration reducing white Americans to
a minority yeah I'm going to go ahead
and say like uh the's not wrong well he
took three three quotes out of context
and stuff them all together into one
sentence so I I would like to see I'm
not saying Joe Biden's not a racist but
I would like to see the full context of
those those statements and also now when
we talk about great replacement I think
it should be repurposed to be like you
know we're not it's not designed to
specifically dilute the power of the
white Americans it's designed to dilute
the power of citizens of the American
citizens that's what's happening that's
the problem yeah I think it is bigger I
think it is bigger in many ways but I
also think this I mean this has all the
Hallmarks of cultural Marxism right
there you go cultural Marxism is
designed to topple the cultural hity or
whoever is perceived to be at the top
you know it's interesting I started
studying this a couple years ago there's
a you know a pastor named doctor VOD
bacham he's a big black dude that looks
like he could play he was a he was a
football player on the rise and then he
became a pastor and he does this
phenomenal series and sermon on cultural
Marxism and how he went on CNN one time
they invited him on after Obama took the
White House and he said that the anchor
was basically asking do bacham hey uh do
you think that race relations in the US
are going to get better now that we have
a black president and um VOD bacham said
no I they're going to get worse and it
surprised the anchor and V bacham went
on to say it's going to get worse
because um Obama set under a cultural
Marxist Pastor named Jeremiah W for a
very long time and if he goes back and
he he he you know kind of gives a
history lesson about cultural Marxism
and and how they tried you know Marxism
to destroy the West traditional Marxism
where you you pit people against each
other economically right you have the
halves and the Have Nots well that
didn't work here in the west because
everybody was too prosperous so what
they do they just revers they they just
made a slight change to the ingredients
instead of dividing us all up on you
know economic classes is we're just
going to divide them all up by race and
it's working tremendously I mean if you
go and you look at how divided we are on
Race you know and it's just to me it's
just disgusting like but you know when I
when I listen to Van Jones right there
you know and what he's saying about um
you know I want white you know what what
I want for white people and to go from
being you know on top of things or what
what do you say Tim from being the
majority majority to be the minority and
to like it that had to me all the
Hallmarks of cultural Marxism the
statement itself is not just an
explanation of what they're doing but an
attempt at incitement to to trigger
reactions which they can then use to
take to gain more power and take
advantage of this you have van Jones
outright saying the racial I don't know
if he's saying I but he does say the
racial Justice left is asking why people
to become a minority which Ian does
bring up there is a third way but in
American politics there's Mass migration
and and birth control advocacy against
having kids and things like this that's
actively happening and so van Jones
saying
that then gets people on the right
people like Viv ramaswami to be like hey
this is the something Democrats have
espoused and then the media immediately
comes out and says they're conspiracy
theorists and they're racists they're
white nationalists and they're Nazis
yeah to Ian's point though I think it's
even bigger than you know the the
replacement stuff and I do think that's
a part of it but you know he said
they're trying it's almost like they're
trying to destroy it right I think they
try and destroy this country every way
they possibly can cuz I don't think they
like the country I don't think that I
think that they want it changed I think
that they they want to top down
totalitarian control they want it to you
know be some Utopia that has you know a
little bit of socialism little bit of
Communism in it and as long as we as
long as Americans feel free prosperous
we we have a constitution we have the
ability to defend ourselves we have
freedom of speech all of that stands in
their way and so I think that it's Death
By A Thousand Cuts and I think that
that's why it just feels like we're
living in Bizarro land Patrick Bet David
talks a lot about uh choosing your
enemies wisely which I think is
fascinating because I'm like I don't
have any enemies I don't want to have
any enemies but I'm like who's my enemy
thinking about today CCP I'm not sure I
don't want my enemies to be you or like
Alexandria kazio Cortez who represents
the Democratic party in a way that you
know I find admirable in some ways at
least it's youthful but like I want my
enemies to be in our country but I and
then I'm like am I just being xenophobic
but do you think the CCP is is involved
in in in this
Marxist obliteration of American
culturalism wasn't do you think that the
CCP the Communist Chinese party the U
that's as far as I'll go do you think
that they're like the masterminds of
this no no it's it doesn't take a person
so like the it's an ideology so like you
know how like if you go to a Catholic
mass right like if you go to a Catholic
mass in the us and then one in you know
in in somewhere in South America they're
going to be similar because Catholicism
has stuff that you are supposed to do to
be Catholic the leftist ideology that he
outlines and I he's 100% right in my
opinion um the leftist ideology that he
outlines like there are there is a whole
you know structure that that people
follow so it doesn't matter that that
you don't need a person that's top
Downing it right they're they they
believe in an ideology and so if you
believe in the ideology you follow the
tenants that are the of the ideology and
you don't need someone to one particular
person to dictate to you because you do
the things that marxists do you look at
the world through a Marxist lens that
just intensifies the value of the
culture War like if it's if it's an in
like an innate emergent phenomenon
that's spreading like wildfire on the
internet there needs to be a better
Wildfire it's not so much emergent it is
it is people that believe it that are
telling other people right now the the
conduit has been basically the the um in
the academy basically schools have been
yeah Academia like have you guys you
guys have I'm sure watched the Yuri bof
videos oh yeah yeah yeah where he talks
about um you know ideological subversion
right he's like I mean if you watch
these videos I mean what Tim when do you
think those were made like the '90s 80s
was the 80s yeah the 80s this guy was in
the US at this time um KGB Defector you
know saying that you know you silly
Americans you think that you know the
KGB we spent most of our resources on
espion James Bond Espionage cuz it's
sexy and it's in the movies he's like no
only about maybe 15% of our budget went
to that stuff right most of it went to
ideological subversion you know putting
people in your institutions your culture
Academia and teaching this crap these
ideologies and and and I think that's
what that's what you're seeing right now
but I I think the uh I've had this
debate 800,000 times actually but I
think the the actual issue was big Tech
and social media and it's not uh so much
the universities I think I think the
universities are a component obviously
because you see all these videos where
someone sends their kids to college and
their kid comes back angry shaved head
you know weird tattoos and things like
that face tattoos or whatever right but
uh what we're seeing with the rise of uh
cultural Marxism and things like this
started around the world all around the
same time which is more indicative of
social media creating the phenomenon
than anything else and there's actually
uh simple explanation so uh the early
social media algorithms favor anything
that makes people angry and so you had
uh Libertarians and I think even like uh
Paul Joseph Watson and like Alex Jones
were posting police brutality videos
because it got people riled up they'd
watch the video and then complain about
it right and so if you're a right
libertarian you're complaining about the
same stuff that eventually black lives
matter started complaining about but
what happens police brutality on its own
only gets 100,000 views racist police
brutality gets a million views so so the
algorithm started favoring content that
pushed things like racism is bad
homophobia is bad anything that would
seem like an injustice and then you had
um the example I always cite is mike.com
which started off as like a Ron paaul
libertarian website turned into a
leftist Social Justice website because
of social media algorithms you write an
article that's in favor of right
libertarian anti-government it does okay
you write a social justice piece it's
got racist sexist anti-gay in the title
bang it's getting a million views so the
company starts putting all their
resources into hiring writers to write
all that stuff and then instantly around
the world you see this in the Lexus
Nexus data every country experiences
except for like Iran and North Korea
they have weird fluctuations but almost
every single country with access to the
basic internet we do sees the same rise
in racism privilege intersectionality
feminism Etc all rapidly happening at
the exact same time yeah I uh when I was
started making internet videos in 06 I I
would make a video called like we are
all the same and like if you believe you
are then you are like that kind of
mindset it was it was that Mark it's
that weird post-modernist thing and it
would they do really well the videos
would do really well with like and the
people that are watching them I don't
know all of them but I think a lot of
them were suffering in their lives so it
sounded good to like yes we are all the
same but we're not we're all similar but
we're not all the same but that that's
that just resonates so powerfully when
you say something like that with
confidence especially if you're someone
that people like that they aspire to be
like thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net